[Music]
over the past decade Iran has embraced
an offensive Regional strategy its
leaders have decided to be more
aggressive in pursuing their foreign
Ambitions those aims include becoming
the regional hegemen destroying the
Israeli State and forcing American
influence from the Middle East
Iran highlighted this offensive strategy
when it launched coordinated attacks on
Regional energy assets throughout 2019
peaking with the large-scale Drone and
missile attack into Saudi Arabia that
September Iran is building and
strengthening a network of Allied States
and militias throughout the Middle East
to support the strategy Iran gives these
actors Advanced military Tech and is
promoting cohesion among them it calls
this network the axis of resistance this
group includes many actors with long
histories destabilizing the region and
threatening the U.S Iran sees itself the
leader of this band of Misfits and
believes it can build them into a strong
Coalition capable of regional dominance
Iran thinks that now is the time for
Action to advance its Regional project
the US ignores this challenge at its own
peril
do you think the U.S should become more
involved in the Middle East as this
threat grows let us know in our comments
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our Scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like And subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI